hey everyone how's it going my name is
Mai you go today is a start of a brand
new series where I'm gonna teach you
about different technologies in under
two minutes we'll introduce concepts
explain things in an easy-to-understand
way and give you the foundation that you
need to dive deeper on your own
this is Tekken 2 so the inaugural topic
for today is front-end development and
we're gonna start the timer so we're
talking about websites there's a lot
that goes on in creating that site what
we typically call the front-end of a
website is the user interface aka the
text buttons images and views that you
see on the screen to interact with the
website or service so front-end
development is the practice of creating
those interactable interfaces the term
is mostly used to describe the
development of web interfaces but it can
be used to describe the development of
mobile and desktop interfaces as well
think about when you need to withdraw
some cash you don't just go up to a pile
of money and just grab whatever you can
because that would break all the rules
of banking the money you get is probably
someone else's and you're probably going
to get the wrong amount of money and
that's why we have ATMs ATMs acts as an
interface to make sure that you're only
pulling the money that you need from the
correct account so think of the ATM like
front-end development where it enables
users to interact with the data in a
safe and user-friendly way so what's in
the stack you might ask well there's
three main technologies that are used
for front-end development the first is
HTML which helps create the UI elements
on the screen the second is CSS which is
basically a set of rules that helps
define the style of a website including
things like font spacing and color and
then there's JavaScript which can also
create elements on the screen through
libraries it helps handle events that
are happening on-screen and it sends and
receives data from the backend and
lastly what are the important factors
when working on front-end development
the first is that tooling and
technologies are always changing so
front-end developers always need to stay
up to date with the newest
the second is creating a flexible and
easy-to-use interface that can be used
by anybody so making sure that it's
accessible and that the UI works on
different devices operating systems
browsers and screen sizes and the last
is to make sure that you can follow a
spec well by being visually detailed
oriented and collaborate and communicate
well with product managers and designers
and that's it
that's front-end development I hope you
liked this episode of tech into there's
gonna be another one about back-end
development which complements this one
really nicely so make sure to hit that
subscribe button so you don't miss out
comment down below if there are any
topics you'd like to see explained in
under two minutes and thank you so much
for watching I'll see you next time bye